Are you recording this right now?
Mm-hmm.
What's up?
Gentlemen.
How's it going?
Good to have you.
What's up?
How's it going?
Are you going to dab me up?
Is that allowed?
Good, good.
How about yourself?
I know.
Me, too.
Good boot.
Oh, that's not my tee.
That was a good kick, though.
That was a good kick.
Good chase.
Guess how many share bars Paveridge has had.
That team's a good pair.
He's about to get...
Two.
He's about to go for his third.
That's good.
Keeping him in business, man.
They're five hours.
That's a lot of work.
Is this a gun?
That's a steel gun.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, right.
Oh, yeah, yo.
Are you kidding me?
Dude, that's so stupid.
Yeah, that was not right.
That was like forward pace.
Monkeys!
Watch this.
They're going to go left here.
Oh, they didn't.
They actually went the right way.
A couple monkeys.
I need to get low again.
Oh.
Oh, great tackle.
Who was that?
That was great.
That's such a...
That's a fun one.
I do that still.
Let's go, Billy.